[MUSIC PLAYING]
ASHISH IPPILI: My
name is Ashish.
Ashish Ippili.
I'm part of the
Professional Services team
within Google Cloud.
And I'm based out of India.
Today we are going
to learn about how
to build a great
messaging application that
can deliver over a billion
plus messages a day
and also see how DCP is probably
the best place to build this.
I joined Google Cloud
about two years ago.
And before joining
Google Cloud, I've
been working with a
number of enterprises
helping them leverage
technologies that are
on collaboration and messaging.
So when I joined Google
Cloud, obviously I
was very keen to understand
how Google does messaging
and how would customers do this.
So when I looked
thereon, I realized
that there are a
number of customers
who use Google Cloud to deliver
messages to their customers.
And we ourselves, as well,
have a number of applications
which does messaging.
Snapchat doesn't need much of
an introduction here I hope.
Hike is a popular messaging
application in India
with over 100 million
registered users.
BBM is still very popular
in India and Asia,
if you're not aware of it.
So they have about 60
million monthly active users.
ShareChat is a custom-made
[INAUDIBLE] platform
for vernacular languages in
India, very popular in Tier 1
and Tier 2 cities.
And then internally
as well, we have
Hangouts, ILO, Chat, and Talk,
and a number of applications.
All of these actually raise the
technologies on Google Cloud
and deliver the
infrastructure stack.
So there's one striking
difference in the applications
that I used to work
earlier and these.
And it's the sheer scale
at which these operate.
The organizations which
I used to work earlier
had tens of thousands of people.
Comparatively, all of these have
millions of users delivering
billions of messages.
So it was fascinating
for me to understand
how the technologies around
this are actually framed,
are put together to ensure
that we deliver messages
to the customers appropriately.
So today, I'm very excited
to share the story of this
is done.
Fortunately for me,
I've had the opportunity
to work with a very
talented team at Hike
who have decided to
move to Google Cloud
about 10 months ago.
So it is in this journey,
when we migrated them
to Google Cloud, I've
learned a lot about how
a messaging application works.
So let's dig a
little deeper and see
the building blocks of a
great messaging application.
First and foremost,
you would obviously
need an infinitely and
insanely scalable load balancer
to take the traffic from
millions of users which
connect to your application.
And then you have to connect the
users to the backend systems.
So you need a
mechanism or a system
to manage these
connections efficiently.
And that's where the connection
handling comes into place.
And then you need to be able to
authenticate the users you're
connecting to and be able to
deliver these messages securely
and consistently.
And obviously, you know, with
so many billions of messages
coming through, you need
a job management system
which basically
manages these jobs
in an asynchronous fashion.
And then, we have a
message processor.
A message processor,
basically what
it does is it takes a
message and understand what
needs to be done with that
message, the action that you
need to take for a single
one-to-one chat or a group chat
or for example, when a user
is online or user is offline,
the action that it has
to take is different.
So the message
processor is the one
which decides what needs to
be done around a message.
And obviously, you
need a message store.
Think of it as a
place or a database
where you store all those
billions of messages
and be able to retrieve those
messages very quickly when
you need them.
So you need a database
which can do this for you.
And then, you need a file
store or an object store
to save all those cute cat
videos, the memes that you
share, and the selfies that
you share with your friends.
So all these object files go and
get stored in the file storage
as such.
And then notification
management.
This is very key.
So the notification management
system, what it basically does,
it identifies whether the
user is online or offline.
And if he's offline, send
him a message saying,
hey, you've got a
message and bring him
back to the application
to check his messages.
So all this is dealt by the
notification management system.
Now last but not the least, you
need a great analytics platform
behind this to take
driven decisions
and be able to be agile
in terms of decisions
to ensure the startup
works really well.
So to see now that you know all
the basic building blocks here,
we're going to see how these
things are put together.
To help explain that, I'm going
to invite Aditya, director
of engineering at Hike.
Aditya.
ADITYA GUPTA: Thanks, Ashish.
Hello, everyone.
I am Aditya Gupta, director of
engineering, Hike Messenger.
Today I'll walk you through
the journey of Hike Messenger.
Hike is one of the popular
messaging apps in India,
started its journey in year
2012 when mobile internet
connectivity was not that
great and smartphone revolution
had just started gaining
popularity with aim to connect
people together.
At present, we have over 100
million plus registered users
extending over 40 million
plus messages over a month.
So how Hike is different
from other messaging apps?
Hike, at present, is
situated at the intersection
of social and content space.
It not only provides
its users a platform
to check without
compromising on privacy,
but also provides a
bite-sized snackable content
in the form of news,
cricket, jokes.
And much more.
Hike is more popular
among youngsters
in the age bracket of 15 to
24 because of its features
like hidden mode, stickers,
timeline, and stories.
Hidden mode allows you to
hide your selected charts
with the rest of the world,
which is a big thing in India,
especially with a lot
of users, especially
with schoolkids who share
their parents' mobile phone
to connect with their friends.
Sticker Shop offers you
over 20,000 stickers
in 40 different languages,
which is a great way
to share your feelings
with your friends
without uttering a word.
Features, like Timeline are for
special memories and Hike News
in over eight
different languages,
is a great way to
remain up to date.
Now, I'll walk you through
the basic messaging
architecture at Hike.
Also we'll be discussing
a few key components
of our infrastructure
and the Google
is helping us to
manage it better.
Sure, next slide.
So Hike messaging runs
on [INAUDIBLE] protocol
over a [INAUDIBLE]
TCP connection
between client and a server.
On a given day at peak, tens
of millions of connections,
clients connect to our
[INAUDIBLE] servers.
So for that, you require
a good load balancer
in the front layer, which was
served by [? edge ?] proxy
in our case.
To connect to
[? edge ?] proxy layer,
we have a DNS [INAUDIBLE],,
which further divides into five
different CNAMES--
[INAUDIBLE], respectively.
Each of the CNAMEs
further resolves
to cluster of [? edge ?]
proxy IP addresses.
Along with this, we used to
maintain a list of public
static IP addresses which were
hardcoded in clients if DNS
resolution fails, which used
to happen because of poor
connectivity of all the
[? ISBs. ?] [? Edge ?] proxy
in turn forwards the connection
to [INAUDIBLE] server and also
to SSR termination.
At the start of
every connection,
client sends a connect
package with UID
and password for authentication.
Connection gets
established only after
successful authentication.
So for that, you
require an Auth service.
After that, whatever
messages client sends,
we used to include them
into the front queues
for asynchronous processing.
There are job
processes which used
to consume these messages
from these queues
and process the message
sent by the client.
To send the message
back to the recipient,
these job processors used
to submit the message
to message delivery service,
which in turn sends [INAUDIBLE]
the message based on whether the
recipient is connected to any
of the [INAUDIBLE] or not.
So this is how basic
messaging works.
So where exactly Google
helps us in this?
For that, I would
say, at every layer,
whether a front end, a
business [INAUDIBLE],,
or a backend database.
While we were learning
GCP, we did a small POC
and found out some major
advantages which prompted
us to move to GCP stack.
Some of the
advantages are, first,
Google provides infinitely
scalable frontend layer
GLB, which can scale quickly
on network or connections both.
It suits perfectly to our
needs, and also we found latency
improvement of around 1.7x as
compared to [? edge ?] proxy
layer.
Second, superior hardware.
We ran a simple test of Redis
benchmark on a similar hardware
machines and found throughput
to be 1.7x more on the GCP
hardware as compared to our
previous cloud provider.
Combining this fact with
managed instanced group, which
can autoscale on CPU load
or any other metrics,
it provides a
simpler architecture
with cost benefits.
Third, Google provides a lot
of APIs, [INAUDIBLE],, ML,
and data processing which
are a lot easier to integrate
if you're on GCP stack.
So this is how our
architecture looks
like after migrating to GCP.
As you can see, we don't
have to maintain a list
of [? edge ?] proxy machines.
We don't have to maintain
a different CNAMEs and also
a list of public static IPs.
GLB just provides you
one public static IP,
which is behind a DNS and
also hardcoded into client
if DNS resolution fails.
As you can see, not all
the processing layer
has been replaced by a
managed instance group which
can scale on CPU or load.
This helps us in
saving a lot of cost.
On a database layer, we
have a lot of footprint
on [? edge ?] base, which we
are now migrating to Bigtable.
It not only provides
a better throughput
but also takes away the
manageability from us.
So this is the
[INAUDIBLE] architecture,
how our messaging looks like.
Now I would like to invite my
colleague Gaurav to deep dive
into two specific
companies-- job processors
and address book database.
GAURAV ARORA: Thank you, Aditya.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Gaurav.
I'm director of engineering
in Hike Messenger in India.
Today I'd like to talk
about a couple of things.
The first one is
the job processors
and then it's the address
book, as Aditya mentioned.
So let's start with
job processors.
So a job processor's
considered an important part
of any messaging
application as this
is where most of the
business logic resides.
Now when we started
building our application,
we started with a
monolithic architecture
where all the components were
in a single deployable unit,
and all the processing
was done synchronously.
Now this approach is usually
the quickest to develop.
And that's one of
the main reasons why
we choose to do it this way.
But very soon, we
hit scale and we
started facing the
pitfalls of this approach.
Now, we had frequent downtimes.
We weren't able to scale
independent components
separately.
Continuous deployment
became a hassle.
And the code base was so
large and complex that none
of the developers were
able to understand it well.
So then we broke the
entire system down
into multiple components.
And the process of delivering
an incoming message
was made asynchronous.
So this is how it looks like.
This is how it looked
like back then.
So all the incoming
messages were
passed through a
sharding function, which
helped to identify a particular
queue on the basis of message
type and the user
ID in the message.
Now, each of these queues
had a single consumer
associated with them which picks
up messages from these queues
and tries to deliver
them to the end users.
Now, as you would know, one
of the main requirements
from any messaging application
is an ordered delivery
of messages.
There can't be more
than one consumer
for each of the queues
or else this guarantee
won't be maintained.
Now this architecture helped
us in separation of components,
each of which could now
be independently scaled
up or down as
[INAUDIBLE] required.
It was much better scalable than
the previous monolithic system
that we had.
However, the system was
still a bit difficult
to scale up as we were
limited by the maximum number
of consumers, which
always had to be
equal to the number of
queues in the system.
In other words, in order
to scale the system,
we needed to increase
the number of consumers.
And to increase the number of
consumers, the number of queues
had to be increased
which in turn required
a change in producers so that
the newly added queues are
taken into account by
the hashing function
that you see up there.
Now, another major issue that
we faced with this approach
was the [? data ?] starvation.
So messages that get
queued in the end
are always delivered
in the end as well.
So older messages
get delivered first.
Now since these queues are
shared by multiple users,
it means what happened that
a user's messages end up
in a queue which is
already full of messages.
And the user
experience of that user
won't be great
because that person
would have to wait
for much longer as
compared to other users.
So we re-architectured
the whole solution
and moved to something
that we internally
call as per user job queue.
This is how it looks like.
So again, all the incoming
messages go through a function.
And a queue is decided
only on the basis
of message type in this case.
And so the producer's
job is only to put it
into an appropriate queue on
the basis of message type.
From there, these
messages are picked up
and placed into one
of the user queues,
depending on which user
it has to be delivered to.
Now, the limitation still
exists that in order
to deliver the messages
in the order in which they
were received, we can still
have only a single consumer
per queue.
But since each user has
its own independent queue,
scaling this architecture
up only requires
us to increase the number
of consumers, which
can be easily put on autoscale.
Now this architecture
in particular
helped us scale to more than
a billion messages a day.
And we hope that it will
continue to scale up
when we get more scale.
So let's move on
to the other one,
other object, which
is the address book.
So address book is one of the
biggest data store in Hike
and has undergone a lot of
transformations over the years.
The use case for address
book is very simple.
Whenever a user joins Hike, the
entire contact book of the user
is synced back to our servers.
And this information is later
used to serve out different use
cases.
The read pattern of this data
is actually two dimensional.
First one is a
forward-looking query,
wherein you want to
query all the users'
data that are in a particular
person's contact book.
And the other is a
reverse relation,
wherein you want
all the users who
have this particular user
in their address book.
Now when we started
building this messaging app,
NoSQLs were very popular.
That was the buzz word.
And MongoDB was one of
the most popular ones
back in those days.
So we also decided to build
our address book using MongoDB.
Now back in those
days, MongoDB was
on its MMAPv1 engine, which used
to acquire our database level
logs.
So initially, the way we
architected the system was we
had one Mongo database for
forward-looking relations
and one database for
reverse relations.
However, since the use
case was very write heavy,
we frequently had scale
issues with MongoDB
because of its DB level logs.
So as an immediate remedy,
what we decided to do was we
sharded the Mongo cluster
into multiple instances.
That helped for a while,
but the rate at which
we were growing
back then, we knew
that we had to do something
completely different.
Now if you look at the data
structure of our address book,
the schema is pretty fixed.
You have user A whose
address book we've picked up.
There is user B in
the address book.
And there is a name and
maybe some other metadata.
So since the schema
was fixed, we
decided to move the entire
load to the traditional RDBMS.
We chose My SQL for that.
And My-- yeah, I think--
yeah.
We moved to MySQL.
Now MySQL served very well
for us for multiple years,
and when we required
more capacity,
we used to scale up the machine.
We were able to vertically
scale our machines up
to about three billion
rows in a single table.
And basically the table looked
like there was a user A,
there is user B, and then
there is a column for metadata.
Now since we required read
patterns on both user A and B,
we simply made indexes
on both of them.
At one point, since we are
vertically scaling this up,
we ended up with a machine
with 104 gigabytes of RAM.
And that was the max
that our service provider
could provide at that point.
So going forward, since
we were still growing,
we had two options.
We could either shard
our MySQL workload
into multiple
instances, or we could
move to a database which
provided sharding by default.
So we chose the latter,
and we moved on to HBase.
So when we started
migrating to HBase,
the initial design that we
chose was a wide schema,
wherein the user ID whose
address book we've picked up,
the user ID became the row
key, and all the contacts
became different
columns in the same row.
Now since a user's address book
can have as little as maybe 10
or 15 contacts and it can go
as big as tens of thousands
of contacts with very frequent
deletions and very frequent
updates, HBase cluster was
going through very frequent
[INAUDIBLE] compactions,
which wasn't desirable at all.
So we knew we had to
change something again.
The next-- what we did
with the HBase cluster
was, instead of
all a wide schema,
we moved it to a
tall schema, wherein
the combination of user ID A and
user ID B became the row key,
and the metadata
was the only thing
that was left for columns.
This architecture served
really well for us.
It's horizontally scalable.
We haven't really felt
any need to replace that.
But when we moved onto
GCP back in late 2017,
we evaluated
Bigtable and realized
that the throughput in Bigtable
was about 1.5 to 1.7 times
faster than the throughput
that we were getting in HBase.
So we decided to migrate
everything on to Bigtable.
One reason to move
that was latencies.
Another reason was it takes away
all the manageability effort
from us.
Basically, Google does
everything under the hood.
So earlier on HBase, whenever
a machine used to go down,
a data node used to go down due
to hardware failure or whatever
other reason, we used to
see spikes in latencies.
But ever since
migrating onto Bigtable,
we haven't really
seen any such spikes.
So Bigtable is
serving really well
for us and we hope
that it continues
to serve the same way.
So that's all I had for
the address book journey.
What's next?
We're actually
doing multiple POCs
for migrating use cases onto
some of the managed services
that Google provides.
Some of the ones
we are evaluating
include Spanner and Bigtable.
So we hope to move
very soon onto those.
Then we're also
evaluating Kubernetes
and trying to
integrate Spinnaker
for continuous delivery
of our code basis.
Now with that, I'd
like to call on stage
[? Sugit ?] from
Google, who will
talk about the basic building
blocks of the analytics
pipeline.
[? SUGIT: ?] Hello.
Thanks a lot, Gaurav.
So let's talk about
data and analytics.
So when you're managing
hundreds of millions of users,
having a solid and
stable data analytics
pipeline becomes really
important because you're always
running AB test, you're always
collecting a lot of events,
and you want to process them
and take data driven decisions
as quickly as possible.
So this is how our typical data
analytics pipeline, a streaming
one, could look.
On the left-hand
side of the screen,
you can see that you have
all your sources, right?
So you have your
analytics events.
You have all your logs.
You have some external
leaders sources coming in.
And then you have your
transactional databases.
All of them can be put
in a messaging queue
if you are building
a streaming pipeline,
or you can just do a
batch processing as well.
And then after that, you need
to have an ETL processing
mechanism to transform that data
and finally dump all of that
into a data warehouse.
And once your data
is in data warehouse,
you can start
building dashboards
for all your
internal teams, start
your business analysis, started
working on your business
intelligence, start getting
more insights out of that data.
And then your own machine
learning folks start--
as soon as they see the data,
they'll start building models
and start working on them.
Let's see how this data
analytics pipeline maps to GCP.
And this is one of the ways
you can build a data analytics
pipeline, a streaming
one onto GCP.
So you have your analytics
events which you can directly
push into a messaging queue.
You can just store
your logs into the GCS,
which is the cloud storage.
External sources,
you can sync, again,
GCS with your-- put in your
external data, third party data
onto to Cloud Storage.
And then you have databases
with a lot of choices
around Spanner or MySQL Postgres
or managed SQL databases.
For messaging queue, we have
our scalable Cloud Pub/Sub.
We use it internally
for a lot of use cases.
And it can scale to very,
very high injection speeds.
Then we have our
managed Hadoop offering,
which is the cloud
data proc in case
you want to build
a batch pipeline
and start directly
processing your logs there.
Once your data is--
inside pops up, you can
build a cloud dataflow
pipeline which is just an
Apache Beam runner onto GCP.
So it's, again, open source.
It's a managed runner, and
it scales automatically.
You can just define
the set of nodes,
and it will scale up and scale
down based on how quickly
and how much money you have
to process that, the money you
are willing to spend on that.
And then very recently--
I think yesterday-- we
announced Cloud Composer which
is our managed Apache Airflow.
You can use Airflow to
control and schedule
your DAGs, which are
your data pipelines, when
do you want to run
them and how do you
want to organize them together.
And then there are
other ways also.
Like you can directly
import your Spanner.
We've recently announced
Spanner backups,
and you can import them
into BigQuery as well.
So that, again, directly
goes to your data warehouse.
Now Apache Beam,
using Apache Beam,
you can dump all of
that data into BigQuery.
You can either stream or
batch upload it into BigQuery.
Then for managing dashboards,
we have our data studio,
which can directly
connect to BigQuery.
And then it can help you build
your internal dashboard which
you can expose to your teams.
For business intelligence, we
have managed Jupyter Notebook's
environment.
We have a Cloud Datalab.
We also have Kaggle,
wherein you can--
if you want to try
out third party data
or build some interesting
insight onto that,
you can use that.
And then finally, we have the
cloud machine learning engine,
which lets you train
your machine learning
models at scale, so
less fully managed.
So you can easily read
data from BigQuery,
and it will automatically
scale out, scale up, scale down
based on your needs.
So all of this end to end
is completely managed.
There are a lot of components.
But usually I think
with Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
and BigQuery, it is quite
straightforward and easy,
and it's good connectivity.
So now let's see how was
Hike's journey, right?
So when you're migrating and
building your data pipeline,
it is--
and you're coming in from
a different environment,
be it on-prem or a
different cloud provider,
it is not always
so straightforward.
There are their own challenges.
And you have your
own experiences.
So I would like
to call in Manjeet
to talk about their
journey around how
did they manage to process
around 2 petabytes of data
as quickly as possible onto GCP.
MANJEET SINGH: Thank
you, [? Sugit. ?]
My name is Manjeet Singh.
And I'm leading the
Data [INAUDIBLE] team
at Hike Messenger.
And today I'll be discussing
about the journey of data
pipeline at Hike
Messenger and also
how Google technologies like
Dataproc, Dataflow, GCS,
BigQuery benefited us.
Hike is a very data-driven
company where every decision
is taken based on data.
So if you talk of data on
an average on a daily basis,
we are generating
approximately 14 to 15 billions
of row, which is coming
around 4 to 5 TB of data.
And in all, we have a
accumulated more than 2
petabytes of data.
Now let's move to
the slide where
we can have the look at
the older data pipeline.
So this is our
how it looks like.
As Aditya explained, we have
a different kind of servers
like [? SMTP ?] servers,
[INAUDIBLE] servers,
analytic servers.
And we have the clients which
are talking to the servers,
and clients generating
their own analytics
logs which are going
to anaylytic servers.
And we were saving
into the log files.
Then other servers, like
[? SMTP ?] and [INAUDIBLE]
servers, they were generating
their own analytic logs
and it was going into log files.
Then we had the crontab setup
on each and every machine,
which were copying our
[INAUDIBLE] data into the cloud
storage.
Then further, we
had crontab jobs
which are copying data
from the cloud storage
to our in-house Hadoop cluster.
So for batching,
we were using Hive.
And it was running on our
own in-house Hadoop cluster.
And all the
aggregated tables were
going into the
[INAUDIBLE] database
for the faster data access.
And [INAUDIBLE] tool
which we were using.
And [INAUDIBLE] was a
[INAUDIBLE] license tool
which we were using.
But with this pipeline, we
were facing many challenges.
So let's have a look at the
challenges that we were facing.
So we need to set
up analytics crong
on every machine, whenever
we are on a new machine.
And there was a loss of logs
in case of machine failures.
And replaying of misfiles
was very messy stuff.
And in the older
data pipeline, we
were processing data
at [INAUDIBLE] level.
So it was not as real
time as we were expecting.
And as we had the
in-house Hadoop cluster,
so we were managing it manually.
It was not an easy job.
And it was all of
us running clusters
so there was a huge
cost associated with it.
And once we migrated to GCP, so
we improved upon our existing
older data pipeline by adopting
various Google technologies
and other technologies.
So let's have a look at
the existing data pipeline
we have at Hike Messenger.
So this is how it looks like.
So now instead of generating
data into log files,
we are generating
data into Kafka.
And then further, we have the
in-house Kafka consumers which
are consuming data from Kafka.
And then we are cleaning
and denormalizing and then
generating the ORC files.
And at every 15 minutes, we
are copying these ORC files
into Google Cloud Storage.
And then we have the Hive.
And we're using
Hive for batching.
And Hive is running on
Dataproc and in Dataproc,
as Dataproc is managed
by Google itself.
So in Dataproc, we are using
two kind of machine instances.
Like one is the fix worker.
Another one is the
preemptive [? old ones. ?]
These are the autoscales.
We have set up the
min and max limit
which get scale out and scale
in based on our settings.
And all the summarized
tables we are
pushing into Google BigQuery.
It is going through
Google Pub/Sub.
And then we have the machine
learning and DS algorithm
which are running on our high
cluster and Google BigQuery.
And then we have the Tableau
as the [? BA ?] tool, which
is talking to Google BigQuery.
And then we got many advantages
after moving to this pipeline.
So let's have a look.
Now, after moving to
this existing pipeline,
we need not to set
up any analytics
of crons for copying data
from the servers to the cloud
storage.
And then fetching data
from Google BigQuery
becomes super fast.
It is more than 10x faster.
And now we are processing
data at 15-minute levels,
so we are moving towards
very near-real-time analysis.
And now we don't have
any in-house cluster,
which is we are using for
data processing now as we
are using Google Dataproc.
So it is managed by Google.
And we are using it in
an autoscaling manner
using the preemptable images.
And then we have the Kafka.
And we can use the
Kafka for building
many data-driven services.
And we are still improving upon
our existing data pipeline.
And so this is how our future
pipeline we will be having.
And in future, what
we're trying to do
is instead of having
in-house Kafka consumers,
we are using Dataflow.
And Dataflow will be
consuming data from the Kafka.
And then what we
are trying to do
is this will be a
metric-driven pipeline.
We are using a rule
engine for generating
the metrics in the data flow
itself, in the transform phase
of the data flow.
And then we are aggregating
and generating the second level
of metrics, and
again aggregating,
and then finally we are pushing
into Google Bigtable and Google
BigQuery.
In Bigtable, we are
putting some data
which is being used by our
application for real time
access.
And then BigQuery will be
our final data warehouse
where our machine learning
stuff and Jupyter Notebooks
and Tableau will be using it.
And this is all
about our journey.
And thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]